off a supermarket display this is how
easily
kyrie sedala bought his lethal weapon
a young man with a known history of
violence and jihadist sympathies
once briefly on mi5's radar
hey kyrie how are you
worried police checked on sir darla the
night before his rampage
he had the knife in a bag with him how
are you feeling yourself
i'm all right you're all right yeah yeah
floating along have you got enough food
yeah
[Music]
yeah yeah i'm blessed thank you 24 hours
later
we need ambulances at full regardless
within 30 seconds he killed three
friends chatting in the park on a
summer's night
then he stabbed and injured three more
nearby
james furlong david wales and joe richie
bennett all died
the three others survived sadala ran
but not for long it took police five
minutes to catch him
sadala arrived in the uk nine years ago
and was refused asylum
after several prison sentences he was
due to be deported
but the home office let him stay because
libya had become unstable
how the killer was ever in a position to
commit these horrific acts
seeking asylum here in 2012 he has
obtained a litany of criminal
convictions
as a family it's been devastating to
lose our much love son
brother and uncle we know that our lives
and the lives of everyone who knew and
loved david will never be the same
we love you david may you james and joe
now rest in peace sadala had denied he
was a terrorist
and made crude attempts to claim he was
mad
but the judge decided his motive was
terror
he had extremist islamic view said the
judge
and he'd used his combat experience with
an islamic militia in libya
to attack his victims with ruthless
speed and brutality
it was a rare and exceptional case said
the judge
and sadala must stay in prison for the
rest of his
life martin brunt sky news at the old
bailey